he's like oh yeah I can say anti-semitic
stuff and Adidas can't drop me and then
they drop me
[Music]
so let's talk about yay Kanye not the
cocaine
but yes Kanye I'll talk about Kanye you
got something to say no he's he's
definitely just like is there more is he
apologizing a bunch now did he go did he
backtrack is he backtracking already
that's what I thought I thought he
backtracked you I thought he wanted up
he did he said sorry for he had the
anti-semitic [ __ ] he was like I'm sorry
y'all I was wilding out I was wrong I'm
sorry for saying all this stuff about
the Jewish media he was saying stuff
like that or unless I [ __ ] that was a
few he uh there's one where he
apologizes for false George Floyd claims
after losing Adidas that's what it was
uh let's see there's another one where
completely wrong I nailed it he might
yeah maybe he says he did apologize for
anticipating remarks the mid ongoing
backlash but like it was probably a
half-assed apology yeah Kyrie Irving's
felt half-assed that's what it what what
even happened with Kyrie Irving why did
he get in trouble
uh he posted on Twitter a link to a uh a
movie or something like that that also
had some sort of
um I guess anti-semitic was it the
beguiled
Kyrie Irving maybe maybe dude we should
we should try to buy the rights to the
big guy because we are single-handedly
like keeping it alive
I don't think it needs a stale they put
it on Hawaiian Airlines do you know that
we can't post that [ __ ] on Tick Tock
that's crazy I can't believe it and it's
acting like we [ __ ] directed it we
might as well get the right exactly
that's [ __ ] up isn't it a cry toront
movie like yes it's like in this [ __ ]
Vault of like was it like the the yeah
the clat turns AMC as in like uh did on
The Tick Tock did you have the actual
like clip from it in there yeah are they
taking it down for copyright it's not
even for copyright it's because it's for
like child endangerment or some [ __ ]
then tell that to quit [ __ ] that's
what I'm saying he was endangering your
childhood but isn't there or he was
saying
we're actually showing it in the correct
light of like look at how [ __ ] up this
is wait that's what we've been doing
[Laughter]
we're just watching it and just going
yes
my favorite scene so every time we're
like last time we're like show Jason
Cheney because it's a great film what
was his reaction he loved it he's like I
support this a thousand percent he's
like oh wow that's very nice yeah
oh so cool very nice of him so Kanye uh
his net worth you guys hear about his
net worth it dwindled like crazy so uh
was only up to a billion he was at 1.5
billion he was his net worth was at
about 1.5 billion uh and recently he is
basically been uh like 200 million with
400 million now it's 400 million
according to Forbes his quality of life
just went down like point five percent
like think about that that's crazy poor
guy dude he probably can't have a pool
cleaner come every week this is like
every other week his Fountain cleaner
can't come everywhere that's right
yeah I love the idea of hating on him
like come on yeah the idea that he's
still lost over a billion dollars and is
still one of the world's wealthiest
musicians with the remainder of his
fortune coming from Real Estate cash his
music catalog and a five percent stake
in ex-wife Kim's shapewear company skims
that's a great company though yeah he's
still gonna be getting a [ __ ] ton of
money for a long time that's just gonna
blow up dude skins the skims have you
seen I wish they made it for men
honestly can I can I keep it a buck have
you ever seen those for men they have it
for men I saw a skim store at them tell
me wait send me a link I think they do
though yeah you saw skins where at the
airport at the airport yeah yeah is
there a bunch of dudes in there pretend
like they're shopping for their wives oh
oh like that my wife needs something
like my wife uh yeah oh yelling so it's
so loud they put on the real body oh
yeah my wife would wear this size I
think hey my wife's a little bigger than
him she's kind of like my size actually
yeah like she's kind of my size like you
know
like my wife like has like this like a
like Flappy a flappy uh what do you call
it uh it's gonna flap out okay what are
you about what do you call that she
needs it's got a little bigger package
for my wife awesome girl shorts Yeah
Yeah from skims
from him
uh I think it was Quicksilver but they
did a collab with stranger things and
the shorts are so [ __ ] this is very
different
what are we talking to collab with
stranger things yeah and it ended up
looking like skins no because we're
talking about men buying female clothes
right oh okay okay all right I'm now I
was like Quicksilver did it go out with
strange things and skips that's why I
bought girl shorts because I put it on
and I like the way that it looks slimmed
you a little it not me it was there's no
guy version of the shorts it looks
[ __ ] dope it's dope yeah it's like
one side is tie-dye the other side is
and it's short because I like short
shorts but then the thing is the nut
area is weird because because it's made
for a vagina they're cut different yeah
yeah there's like a diva cup inside
me the whole day it feels like IUD in
there I like Joe's realization that like
girls clothes is cut different yeah he's
like yo you guys hear about this in the
crotch area you ever seen women's
bicycles
there's like a dildo on the seat
like every time dude it's a basketball
tampons
it's about Quicksilver and stranger
things yeah dude that's so funny
so what what did he actually apologize
about
uh I honestly I barely heard [ __ ] oh so
this isn't about a Nick just about his
net worth they just [ __ ] accepted me
I thought this article was his apology
tour no this is about Kanye I just feel
like we got to be talking about Kanye in
general because like he's you know he's
all the rabies all the news at the end
of the day I know all of us here at some
point had to be fans of his music oh
dude yeah his Dave in his days
you guys do you guys have any of those
issues where it's like oh somebody did
something weird so I can't hear the
music nah dude I like Clint Eastwood
yeah there's nothing I can goddamn do
about it you know what's weird is that I
don't idolize and worship humans at all
I feel like everyone has a [ __ ] up
side and a creative good side or
whatever so then that little element of
who they are isn't the whole person
right so yeah this [ __ ] can't be
a sick [ __ ] but then if he made
a cool thing then that's that's what I
can respect that cool thing for that
crap yeah even Hattori Hanzo oh
especially hard Tory Hanzo even Michael
Jackson Bros
especially Michael Jackson he loves his
music it's best he loves his music he
loves the titling too he loves it but
that never happened that never happened
at all it's a different stance yeah you
maintain that huh yep and by the way
they caught
a lot of porn in this house that we're
adults so he likes adult porn who's his
Maids porn
his Butler's in his Maids
yeah there you go they planted it
um so I I just like the balls on Kanye
to be able to go into a podcast and say
anti-semitic stuff and then he's like
he's like oh yeah I can say anti-semitic
stuff and Adidas can't drop me and then
they drop it
it's classic that's so funny it's so
wild
and Adidas took a major hit by driving
in two bro dude like because I got I got
a family member who works at Adidas
um their whole department they have like
over 200 plus employees or something my
number's probably wrong but I think it
was like over 250 employees their whole
building that has been in disarray for
like months and then when the decision
finally came out it's kind of like that
that whole is gone now it's shut down
you know what I mean like a but they all
lost jobs the entire industry in essence
you know what I'm saying is like playing
a while now dude that's yeah that's what
it takes that's how [ __ ] big he is
though too right like if you're talking
about like 250 million or something like
that can your can your friend get us
some Yeezys Yeezy they discontinued them
so now they're going to be more rare and
more valuable right they're potentially
going to be more round more value what
was the biggest thing because I think um
before that he did some other [ __ ] right
and then they didn't care but once he
talked about the Jewish that's what all
the Jewish people got mad and then
started firing him
yeah that's what happened right I mean
that's like that's the no the point of
no return I think like you could talk
about black people you could do the
white lives matter you could do all that
but do not touch the Jewish stuff yeah
because when you hit that it's like
there's no way to rationalize that yeah
but he was being too wild with it yeah
and also also with client too if he does
anything with you know it's one of those
okay speaking from Asian perspective
right if he talks about anything black
related
foreign
or even if he says white life matters
it's almost like that's still the
dichotomy of the conversation but once
you go into like a whole different you
know group of people and like talking
about some other [ __ ] yeah you're like
wait what what the [ __ ] you know what I
mean so it feels like he was in a bar
fight
and then like yeah he like he like
accidentally he's just [ __ ] swinging
and then he hits some guy in the elbow
or something like a Jewish guy in the
face and then he doubles down and he's
like yeah well good [ __ ] you man
just say you're sorry you hit the guys
sorry it seemed like he was on such a
role that he was like he really probably
thought he could say anything and then
he dared to do that one and another
thing and it's like oh no dude nobody's
above that one He piled on because I
think even if like let's say that he
said [ __ ] about Asians I think he would
have honestly still been fine and that's
sad yeah you know why because we're
[ __ ] no it's because you don't bite
the hand that feeds you man you're gonna
get fired by your bosses if you talk
[ __ ] about that did you guys see the
Dave Chappelle Saturday Night Live yeah
um I didn't get to watch it yet I heard
it's great it's [ __ ] great he did a
stand-up uh he just does Saturday Night
Live yeah opening monologue I heard he's
in the game with those ones it's
hilarious I heard you lied to them about
what he was going to do and then he he
like did completely a different set than
Universal yeah but I hadn't seen it yet
that's even more brilliant what was it
what was it what happened well basically
he he addresses all this stuff he talks
about Kanye he talks about
and and you know there's different
people on the news now that are like you
know kind of giving Dave Chappelle a
little bit more um you know backlash
again but he even talks about uh one of
his jokes he's talking about how nobody
should ever put two words together and
be successful for it and the stewards
like that and Jews so you can't use
those two words together ever in a
successful way I never see anybody do
good after that and then he talks about
like blah blah he's like bro like Adidas
was founded by Nazis and they still get
it you know what I mean like yeah so he
goes off
that's hilarious he goes off but you
know he never like lies right like he
kind of like says what's on the dot he
was talking about The Stereotype of like
yeah there's a lot of people in
Hollywood that are Jewish he's like that
happens
there's a lot of Jews but you know it
doesn't matter because a lot of black
people in Ferguson we don't run that
place yeah yeah yeah yeah and it's like
the perfect joke dude but that's like
saying there's a [ __ ] nail conspiracy
by Vietnamese people there is and then
like
you just I mean it's just the way that
they got into the industry is because
they didn't have any opportunities and
someone taught them how to do nails and
then they just brought their family and
then I was watching this doc about how
Jewish folks got built Hollywood is
because they couldn't get other jobs
anglos didn't hire them so they started
buying into movie theaters out into the
uh out in the east coast and they're
like well instead of renting in Elite
licensing movies why don't we just make
our own and then that's how Hollywood
was built so it's like all of these
immigrant groups in America in history
has found an industry and they dominate
an industry because they'll be like hey
you want to come America just like the
cambodians with donut shops so then I'm
like why is that a conspiracy like it
happens with so many different ethnic
groups in the states so that doctor
Kanye dude make him watch it the real
conspiracy to me is why we can't post
Pepe memes because I [ __ ] love Pepe
and everyone the Frog because it's white
supremacist people were wilding out with
Pepe like some bad people were wild out
with Pepe we all love Pepe and then now
Pepe the frog is like this like where he
is the ADL said he's like a hate symbol
and I'm like yeah
the sweet little frog the Frog memes
wait how did that happen because the
troll became real yeah so like let's say
like people were trolling that it was uh
it was white supremacy symbol all that
stuff and then they were just using it
on 4chan to like you know like it's like
this look it's the first thing that
comes up you put will you search
the first thing comes up
is yeah they just decided it was yeah
and then just because some white
supremacist dudes wore it on a rally
just to be because they're also trolls
too then they made it their symbol but
it's not there something it's not it's
like if all the proud boys suddenly wore
[ __ ] uh Quicksilver then that's the
new [ __ ] hate symbol Quicksilver of
stranger things
that's my share Colleen asked what the
ADL is that's what I asked definition
Nick really wants to
me I know what it is
[Music]
foreign